pêche on va revenir à la tradition avec
le langage vocal le patois comme on dit
alors lorsqu'on ne connaît pas la région
alors qu'on est très loin on dit oui
là-bas il parle le ch'ti ou le jeu qui
me va pas du tout le chimiste est pas du
tout un langage ici c'est simplement là
comme ça que les poilus de la guerre de
appelez les gens du nord mais quand vous
dites il parle de tbilissi tout le monde
rigole parce que c'est pas ça du tout en
fait ici on parle le picard de boulogne
à maubeuge alors il ya des accents
différents bien évidemment mais il ya
des racines communes et c'est surtout un
langage de bonne humeur en langage de
tradition et ont certains disent tu ici
que le patois devrait être remboursé par
la sécurité sociale car c'est un
véritable anti dépresseurs c'est la
lutte contre la morosité
alors on a choisi pour vous en parler
d'eux nordiste pur jus qui vont aux
jurés qu'il ne pleuvait pas à lille
aujourd'hui marianne masse et dominique
maes reportage un fier aidé à merci pire
tous chopin et ald et 1 l'auriez-vous
reconnu c'est bien le capitaine haddock
qui jure ainsi en patois la version
picarde des bijoux de la castafiore est
né ici à tournai sous une plume belge la
seule bd traduite en patois du nord est
ici quand on ignore on oublie les
frontières on a été la capitale de la
france avant que paris ne soit c'est
clovis kaki détourné pour s'en aller
vers le test et vers paris mais il n'est
pas pratique le patois et le patois est
resté et il a vécu sa vie de patois
attrapant vol des accents colorés
damien tournée de dunkerque à
valenciennes pour un cheval on dira un
grand un bide et un gros interview ça
peut être certaines expressions par
exemple pour dire à un torchon a donc
choisi seaway 5 première fois que le
prendre le plombier venu à la maison il
m'a dit pas si one way 5 je reste un peu
ch price coop jusqu'à 4 aux hommages no
plus tôt on les définit pas on les mange
des mots qu'on mange surtout en famille
parce qu'à l'extérieur c'est parfois mal
vue mal compris un peu comment dire
connoté
on parle et on parlait patois quoi
et parce qu en chantier de chez nous par
les français en fait à l'école de parler
patois
il est sorti par la fenêtre
il revient aujourd'hui par la
grand'porte le patois picard à ces
écoles il est même enseigné à la fac de
lettres modernes il ça parle telma
canaux du bien à l'écouté casquette et
tout est à tickets à travers sucette
ça n'est pas du français déformés cg
d'un système autonome proche du français
mais qui a sa propre légitimité disons
on veut populaire et qui a une
ancienneté constaté attestée depuis
quelques bilans très surpris de trouver
le moule en dvd chez balzac
on en en devenant plus un conte ce parce
que en picard bon il ya le correspondant
à des faits qui veut dire en rachète
arranger on là rien de repères il
parlait picard et flamand wallon n'a
vraiment pas loin du coin
j'ai un peu mou j'ai voulu saisir
l'occasion la langue qui part faire du
mal si ce retour aux sources
aujourd'hui il y à deux fois plus
d'élèves qui étudie les langues
régionales qu'il ya dix ans tweed
capitaine et ben ouais la suite elles se
parlent plus qu'elle ne s'écrit pour
l'instant on parle en effet d'une énième
loi nous donner un statut aux langues
régionales jeunesse là c'est encore
notre histoire tout jusqu'à l'hôpital
alors